isabelle facon merci de répondre à
france 24 vous êtes maître de recherche
à la fondation pour la recherche
stratégique
on assiste à quoi une violation de
l'intégrité de l'ukraine de la loi
internationale aussi
oui tout à fait sauf que ce n'est pas
tout à fait nouveau puisque pour le c1
depuis 2015 la russie soutient les
séparatistes du donbass on sait aussi
qu'elle a distribué c'est terminé ces
dernières années six cent mille à 800000
passeports aux habitants des deux
républiques autoproclamées donc dans une
certaine mesure ce n'est pas tout à fait
nouveau ce qui est nouveau c'est la
reconnaissance effective par la russie
de ces deux territoires séparatistes
depuis l'annnonce du déploiement d'une
force dite de maintien de paix
qui nous rappelle aussi quelques
souvenirs puisque en 2008 en géorgie
déjà il y avait eu des événements un
petit peu similaire gagne finalement
vladimir poutine à reconnaître ces deux
zones on a le sentiment que le gain
paraît limité alors tout dépend d'avoir
de si c'est finalement une étape finale
ou si c'est une première étape vers
d'autres choses encore plus préoccupante
ce qui semble vrai c'est que pour la
russie un des objectifs alors cette
montée en pression depuis quelques mois
déjà avec la la pression militaire à la
frontière avec l'ukraine et puis aussi
les demandes faites des exigences posées
par là aussi aussi bien à l otan qu aux
etats-unis en termes de garanties de
sécurité
il y avait la réalisation des accords
2010 portant justement sur le statut de
ces deux entités séparatistes sur le
territoire de l'ukraine or sur ce sujet
là la consigne n'a pas vu les choses
bouger dans le sens qu'elle souhaitait
et donc voilà c'est une façon pour la
russie doit fermer ce dossier la
question que l'on peut se poser c'est si
la russie va aller plus loin ou si elle
va considérer que là elle a suffisamment
envoyé son message à l'ukraine et aussi
aux occidentaux on peut s'inquiéter
quand même parce que la pression
militaire à la frontière entre les
exercices en biélorussie tout ça
continue et on peut se demander c'est
finalement par rapport aux objectifs
pardon stratégique de poutine qui sont
d'une part faire en sorte que l'ukraine
reste dans sa sphère d'influencé et
d'autre part obtenir une redéfinition
des règles de l'architecturé de sécurité
européenne et peut-être qu'il a estimé
qu'il faut peut-être aller plus loin
pour mieux établir le rapport de force
vous parlez de ces êtres ces accords de
minsk que signent en 2014 entre
ukrainiens russes sous l'égide des
français et des allemands ou vladimir
poutine reproche aux occidentaux de ne
pas avoir poussé kiev à appliquer ces
accords de paix est d'avoir seulement
cherché à geler le conflit on a le
sentiment aujourd'hui que ces accords de
paix n'était pas applicable alors c'est
vrai que dès le départ en fait il y
avait quelque chose déséquilibré dans
ces accords 2000 ce que puisqu'ils ont
été signés par l'ukraine au terme de
très longues négociations s'en souvient
angela merkel et françois hollande une
très petite nuit mais qui à l'été donc
signé dans un contexte du crème était
vraiment sous très forte mais qu'aux
militaires russes elle avait encaissé
des défaites sur le terrain très forte
et donc il fallait cesser les hostilités
et donc l'ukraine depuis n'a eu de cesse
de proposer une autre interprétation des
désaccords de mitry en tout cas il était
assez clair dès le départ qu'elle ne
souhaiterait pas à les faire appliquer
puisque elle estimé qu'il était trop
défavorable alors que moscou a proposé
une lecture plus orthodoxes si l'on peut
dire de ces apports en considérant que
ce qui avait été signée devait être mise
en place et elle est aussi entre les
deux parties mais ça relève de ces
divergences initial une divergence sur
l'ordre dans lequel les chances de l'est
se faire le la reprise de contrôle par
l'ukraine delà du contrôle de la
frontière avec la russie
les les discussions et les maisons à
prendre sur le statut des deux
républiques autoproclamées sûr ça aussi
il y avait un désaccord entre les deux
parties et effectivement la russie
estime parce que c'était en 2015 que
nous emmener en 2022 que sans doute la
communauté internationale incarnée
notamment par les deux parrains de ces
apports la france et l'allemagne n'ont
pas fait suffisamment pour convaincre
kiev à telle enseigne d'ailleurs que
c'est en étant là aussi elles mêmes
essayer de rapprocher les états unis
dans cette affaire là pour essayer en
estimant que les états unis seraient
plus volontaire
en tout cas valu à poutine a réussi une
série de coups géopolitique il ya eu la
biélorussie cette intervention pour
bâillonner l'opposition et la réprimer
il ya maintenant cette reconnaissance
des régions séparatistes en ukraine et
face à lui il y à un occident qui
n'apportent pratiquement aucune riposte
à part les sanctions pourquoi cette
timidité
bas parce que d'abord je pense que
personne n'a très envie d'entrer en
conflit militaire avec avec la russie et
ce qui est frappant c'est que ça a été
dit très tôt dans les premiers temps de
cette montée en puissance de la pression
russe l'otan les états unis où beaucoup
parlé du besoin de renforcer la
dissuasion via l'otan de renforcer les
pays frontaliers membres de l'entente
les frontaliers de la russie la mer
noire etc mais il n'a jamais été
question d'aller prendre les armes pour
défendre
l'ukraine alors dans ce cas de voilà ce
qui demeure c'est effectivement larmes
des sanctions mais on a le sentiment
actuellement que finalement la russie
pour l'instant en tout cas le
gouvernement russe mais le primat sur
les enjeux géopolitiques qui sont de
taille dans sa perspective par rapport
aux enjeux économiques avec le sentiment
d'avoir peut-être bien tenu face aux
sanctions prises précédemment suite à
l'annexion de la crimée est ce qui n'est
pas tout à fait vrai mais c'est pas tout
à fait faux nantes non plus dans
certains domaines et sans doute que la
russie compte sur le fait que au sein de
l'union européenne notamment certains
états sont plus dépendants des relations
économiques avec la russie et qui va
valoir sans doute trouver des compromis
difficiles entre pays européens et que
peut-être ça peut la protégée de
sanctions qui seraient trop trop
douloureuse et c'est vrai que ce que
l'on voit pour l'instant
sanction du côté américain et même
européen ça peut paraître relativement
qui m'aurait au regard des agissements
de la russie alors pour voir si les
choses peuvent évoluer dans paul en
faire un nom et un point qu'il ait passé
un présent c'est de voir normalement de
suspendre la série
fameux gaz de beaucoup défrayé la
chronique
effectivement merci isabelle facon m